[Music]
so journaling day one
let's go
[Music]
so i wanted to try to journal for seven
days to see how it would affect my mood
so every day i tried one different
prompt such as todayi notice dot dot
these type of problems can really help
you in your writing and also lets you
know different things around you that
you would have otherwise perhaps
discarded so i will put a little list of
all the prompts i use and you can join
me in this journey
[Music]
[Music]
just like
[Music]
and one day she said
write me a love song cause i know you'll
make it beautiful
and maybe i'll
call you my sweetheart
and promise nobody can steal me away
then i am your horse
cause i want you and i wanted you to
know
[Music]
he looked at her and then he smiled and
picked up a pen he's like he love me but
don't love me
something about our eyes and how they're
always shining
or something cliche
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so i think everyone has an ideal day in
mind waking up early getting a lot of
stuff done seeing your friends and
working out etc
and to kind of see where these
aspirations could fit in it is handy i
find to first write out exactly what
you're doing during the day such that
you can see how you actually spend your
time
and i think this works best in a pie
chart visualization
so a large part of my day is been doing
research which i have to do for my phd
also creative work at the moment for
youtube for example
i do love doing sports as well such as
yoga or hanging with friends i spend a
large time doing that and also just
eating and enjoying life these kind of
common things that you have to do
and
lastly i do think i also spend a large
part of my time just being lazy and
procrastinating on the task i have to do
so i think i could benefit from some
time management there
[Music]
thank you
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so i've been using this website habitika
to kind of swap habits so what i do is i
think of a habit that i have
then i think of why i do it and then i
try to swap it with a new habit
so for example
taking really long naps and i do it to
get energy and then instead i want to go
outside
so yeah try to do this for yourself as
well
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so i'm in my bed mark now for the
last journaling challenge
and something i personally really like
to do sometimes is to
write
or journal from quotes
so it's usually a book that i'm reading
or some kind of magazine i usually type
out little quotes that i find
personally really inspiring or something
to think about so right now i'm reading
the book uneducated
as you can see right here
and it's really nice so
i will be writing a little quote from
that one
and then kind of write my thoughts out
as to
what i think about it and the nice thing
in that book it starts with mental
health especially her father has she's
guessing some type of bipolar disorder
which is something in
my environment that i also struggled
with so it's kind of nice to see how
this author thought about it and wrote
about it and to get my thoughts about it
on paper so yeah i'll be doing that
[Music]
you